la tendance se confirme jour après jour
avec un total de plus de 12 millions
d'infections au qu'ovide 19
l'europe est la région du monde où le
virus circule le plus rapidement devant
la flambée des chiffres chaque pays a
décidé de prendre de nouvelles mesures
pour freiner l'épidémie
c'est le cas notamment de l'espagne ou
un équivalent de l'état d'urgence lé
état d' alerte et un couvre-feu sont en
vigueur sur tout le territoire
bien qu'il s'agisse de mesures moins
stricte qu'au printemps dernier lorsque
le pays avait été confiné ce tour de vis
est loin de faire l'unanimité
exemple avec cette manifestation samedi
à madrid des centaines de personnes se
sont retrouvées pour dénoncer ces
mesures dans ces moments que nous vivons
actuellement des mesures sont prises
beaucoup d'entre elles ont une légalité
douteuse nous sommes en état d'urgence
déguisé parce que nous avons été mis en
état d' alerte par une privation des
droits et libertés fondamentaux qu'il
peut être appliquée qu'en cas d'état
d'urgence ou de siège
nous sommes donc ici pour dénoncer cela
et défendre la légalité et la liberté la
liberté d'expression la liberté de
pouvoir se déplacer que vous ne voulez
ils viennent de décréter un état
d'exception déguisés et illégale avec un
couvre feu la censure des réseaux
sociaux et l'étouffement de la
principale source de richesse et de
travail de notre pays
l'hospitalité et le tourisme
au royaume uni pays le plus endeuillé
d'europe avec près de 49 mille décès
c'est cette fois du côté de liverpool
que les manifestants ont samedi fait
part de leur mécontentement à nouveau
confier une partie de la population à
défiler dans les rues parfois de manière
plus virulente obligeant à plusieurs
reprises la police à faire usage de la
force
même mesure de confinement d'un mois
chez le voisin allemand
mêmes scènes de eur et d'arrestations à
leipzig où environ vingt mille personnes
se sont réunies pour réclamer la levée
immédiate des restrictions aux droits
fondamentaux
les affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre s'y sont prolongés jusque dans
la soirée
au lendemain de ces mouvements de
protestation en gala merkel s'est
exprimée au sujet du vaccin au cours de
son allocution
la chancelière allemande a sans doute
voulu apaiser les tensions vis à nous
espérons que les premiers vaccins seront
approuvés très prochainement ensuite
bien sûr il n'y aura pas encore assez de
vaccins disponibles sur tout je tiens à
le souligner encore une fois personne ne
sera obligé de se faire vacciner mais
c'est une décision volontaire notre
objectif prioritaire est de faire en
sorte que la population soit immunisée
dans son ensemble nous savons par
d'autres épidémies qu'avec environ 60 à
70 % de la population est muni zay soit
en ayant traversé la maladie eux mêmes
soit par la vaccination le virus et plus
ou moins vaincu ensuite nous pouvons
également levé toutes les restrictions
jusque là nous devons encore vivre avec
certaines restrictions que le virus nous
impose à l'image de l'allemagne qui a
samedi enregistré un nouveau record en
24 heures avec 23 1399 infection au
coronavirus l'europe est frappée de
plein fouet par la deuxième vague avec
280 mille cas recensés quotidiennement
et un bilan de plus de 300 mille décès
au total le vieux continent doit essayer
de trouver le juste équilibre pour
freiner l'épidémie est contrarié au
minimum sa population et bien sûr tâche
est de limiter la casse sur le plan
économique